hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer map vorstellung von stats play und
häcksel namens team fortress 2 viel spaß
so wir vorhin schon hören konnte ist das
eine team fortress 2 map in minecraft ja
das funktioniert und ja das beansprucht
wirklich eine menge redstone arbeit das
werde ich euch gleich am ende mal zeigen
und ihr fragt euch noch bestimmt was was
ist denn jetzt eine map vorstellung
ich werde eventuell wenn ihr dafür seid
euch ab und zu ein paar coole adventure
maps vorstellen die ich ganz toll findet
ihr vielleicht spielen könnte oder so
und schreibt mir doch einfach mal in die
kommentare beziehungsweise bewertet das
video mit einem daumen hoch wenn ihr
wollt dass ich öfters mal vielleicht ein
paar maps vorstelle und ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt an ich habe mir die
map vorhinein mal ganz kurz angeguckt
ich weiß dass es mit diesem comments
blog gemacht wird und man kann diese map
nur mit der neuen version 37 a spielen
das heißt man klickt einfach die auf den
button
man macht der rechtsweg drauf dann sind
hier die türen offen ihr seht in den
tschad mission wiegens in two minutes
man geht hier rein und dann kann man
sich hier irgendwas auswählen was man
will gc wie dem ob-büro soldiers cold
dann gibt sie noch space night magic ich
nehme natürlich den 2 weil mein skin mit
dem doch sehr ähnlich dann macht man
einfach rechtsklick drauf bekommt man
hier seine items und man wird anhand
dieser comments blogs und testens und
dispenser in den spa bereich der webcast
rein teleportiert die leute die team
fortress 2 spielen lassen das video wo
gehen meine sachen gehen in die weg das
liegt daran dass ich gerade im game ort
in dem man kurz aus dem game ort raus
ihr könnt euch dann hier so ein paar
sachen aufsetzen mainz kind ist gerade
einfach weg weil ich ja zwei bin bisher
also ich bin also es gibt den porträts
spiel das selber nicht so oft aber es
gibt den zwei und da ist man glaube ich
teilweise unsichtbar weil man dann ja
immer ich sag mal mann ist der agent
naja jedenfalls würde ich sagen ist man
hier in der map ich mach mir mal kurz
normalen gaylord man kann dann anhand
von ein paar schaltern oder so dann auch
hier raus und diese tore zum beispiel
runtermachen ich mach das mal ganz
einfach so ganz professionell moment so
ich wollte euch nämlich diesem app an
sich zeigen und zwar finde ich die
extrem geil
die wurde von spring halb pixel und dem
kompletten team glaube ich aufgebaut ich
glaube verrat und partner waren auch
noch dabei man hat halt jede einzelne
gebäude die wirklich komplett so aus der
team fortress 2 map auch so übernommen
wurden
man hat hier diese ganzen rails über die
website kann auch überall hin glaube ich
und zwar wird das dann am ende so
ablaufen dass diese mission wie ihr hier
im chat mission beginnt im moment ich
kann es mal ganz kurz hier so einstellen
hier steht nämlich im chat mischen wir
uns im team wenn es das war vor einer
minute oder so und dann steht da gleich
in zehn sekunden geht's los dann wird
man aus diesen containern da unten raus
gelassen wo ich vorhin rausgeflogen bin
da jetzt nämlich keine lust zu warten
ich kann da kurz noch mal reingehen wo
wir das was hier was hier ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher
egal jedenfalls erlebt man nach diesen
genau da unten steht als fünf sekunden
da wir werden dann diese pisten teile da
hoch gefallen und dann wird man daraus
geschickt sag ich mal dann kann man aus
dem sportbereich raus und dann kommt das
blaue team irgendwie von da hinten und
das rote team von da hinten und dann ist
hier das alles ein purer deathmatch
kampf das ist auf jeden fall eine extrem
geile map für solche ganzen ich sag mal
pvp matches
außerdem ist das wirklich so aufgebaut
dass man das ganze ohne mods spielen
kann und der generiert sich halt immer
die zeit selber von dass er immer tag
macht und so weiter und schaut euch das
mal anders ist hier das komplette
redstone gewerkelt was unter der map
herrschen das ist echt echt aus dem
einfach nur ums mal auf englisch sagen
ließ und wild lions on stage ist in
going also die haben das recht als er
sich auf englisch geschrieben damit die
untereinander wirklich immer wissen wann
jetzt genau
was hier aktiviert wird sage ich bin ja
selbst nicht so der größte redstone
wisst ihr ja man hat halt auch diese
neuen comment box die man halt mit
dieser 13 13 730 oder irgendwie so ganz
verbraucht man hat auf jeden fall eine 3
stage redstone schaltung das ganze sieht
so krass wenn man sich das mal anguckt
diese ganzen redstone schaltungen das
ist schon ein hammer mäßige arbeit
gewesen
ihr wisst alle dass ich von redstone
nicht so viel ahnung hat von daher kann
ich euch dazu nicht viel erklären aber
ich hab selber team fortress 2 gespielt
ich muss sagen die map nachgebaut ist so
genial einfach nur geworden
also ich kann echt nur ein kompliment
dafür aussprechen
ich würde dieser map wenn diesmal im
alten diamanten ranking mache würde ich
ihr glaube ich so zehn von zehn
diamanten geben ganz einfach weil es
perfekt ist es ist einfach nachgebaut
von damals was ziemlich genial ist und
wir auch schon sie zitiert dann die
pisten runter gefahren die ich vorhin
kaputt gemacht habe also das sollte
nicht passieren dass ihr können zeigen
und zwar wenn ihr darauf geht bekommt
die entweder hier
wenn ihr darauf geht bekommt ihr was zu
essen wenn ihr darauf geht bekommt ihr
eine passion glaube ich oder hält auch
noch was zu essen ich weiß es nicht ganz
genau kennt auch hier dann einfach
rechtsklick machen dann fällt ihr aus
dem web was eigentlich nicht passieren
sollte
das verstehe ich nicht naja ich glaube
man stirbt dann einfach extra und kann
dann halt wieder dabei nicht ganz mein
team rot dann will ich mal den hieraus
transport zum beispiel bei team rot und
da bin ich dass ich das hier ist der
spot von team roter kann ich mir noch
mal ein paar sachen hier holen wenn die
zeit abgelaufen ist kann man dann auch
hier ausnützen ganz einfach und dann ist
man auch direkt im im kampf sage ich mal
dann zieht man sich schnell die sachen
an die ich mir gerade in die wegwerfe
und dann kann man jedenfalls und dann
kommt da hinten die die blauen und dann
kann man die da wegklappen naja ihr
findet in der beschreibung einen trailer
zu der map findet auch den download da
drin also wenn ihr einen server hat
packt die map darauf macht die pvp
matches draußen ist auf jeden fall sehr
interessant natürlich sagen jetzt was
von der ersten map vorstellung ich weiß
die welt ein bisschen spontan und und
informativ aber ich wollte einfach mal
fragen ob ihr sowas allgemeinen öfter
wollt also öfter heißt jetzt nicht jeden
tag sondern
dass ich so was vielleicht noch mal
mache und dann würde ich sagen sehen wir
zum nächsten video wenn ihr das video
gut findet dann bewertet es bitte mit
einem daumen hoch wenn es nicht so gut
findet bewertet es mit einem daumen
runter und schreibt mir das feld in die
kommentare bis zum nächsten mal